and in a report claims President Trump
repeatedly rejected his national
security teams advice to release
hundreds of millions of dollars of
military aid for Ukraine the temporary
decision to hold up that aid is at the
center of the president's impeachment
he spent the weekend at his Florida
resort lashing out at House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi on Twitter Ben Tracy is
there in West Palm Beach traveling with
the president Ben what's the latest that
he's saying well good morning clearly
the president is still angry at Speaker
Pelosi for what he views as an unfair
impeachment process and lawmakers are
now facing off over what the president's
impeachment trial could look like in
January Senator McConnell the Republican
leader are gonna try to rig this trial
right from the start
Democrats are standing by House Speaker
Nancy Pelosi s decision to hold on to
the articles of impeachment the speaker
should do what's necessary in order to
make sure that there is in fact a fair
proceeding Republicans see it
differently the son will have a fair
trial and you'll see an acquittal this
as new details emerge about the
administration's decision to freeze
millions in aid to Ukraine according to
the New York Times opposition the orders
from the president's top national
security advisors was more intense than
previously known it describes one August
oval office meeting intended to persuade
the president to release the aid with
defense secretary mark s / Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo and former national
security advisor John Bolton in which
Bolton reportedly told the president
this is in America's interest mr. Trump
responded Ukraine is a corrupt country
we are pissing away our money Bolton is
among the witnesses that Democrats want
to hear from in a Senate trial one
witness the president wants former Vice
President Joe Biden is now reversing
himself after previously saying that he
would refuse to testify at the
impeachment trial even if subpoenaed by
Congress
Congress in fact legitimately asked me
to do here in Florida President Trump
had a phone call with Russian President
Vladimir Putin yesterday and we only
know this because the Kremlin released a
readout of the phone call the White
House has said nothing about it
Moscow says that Putin called Trump to
thank him for US intelligence that
helped prevent terrorist attacks in
Russia
Jericka alright Ben Tracy for us at the
White House or in Palm Beach rather West
Palm Beach thank you so much
you